well plan trilogies and intricately
connected film universes have
revolutionized the idea of sequels
sequels are now highly anticipated and
do quite well at the box office some
less successful franchises have a long
history of keeping on however providing
more content than anyone expected
here are some movies with way more
sequels than you thought the Scorpion
King after 2 Indiana jones-style
adventures with Brendan Fraser and
Rachel Wise the filmmakers of the mummy
movies realised that the true future of
the franchise lay with Dwayne Johnson
who had a supporting role in the mummy
returns as Matthias the ancient Scorpion
King and so came the third movie in the
series of prequel / spin-off called the
Scorpion King it was a big hit but
Johnson bowed out of plane Matthias
again the direct-to-dvd prequel the
Scorpion King to rise of a warrior
starred an actor and model named Michael
köppen days of our lives veteran Victor
Webster took over for the next two
Scorpion King entries the Scorpion King
three battle for redemption and the
Scorpion King for quest for power he was
joined by a few other up and comers as
well
Noble destroy Air Bud in 1997 Disney's
Bud verse started quietly with the
theatrical release of Air Bud
it's the charming and unlikely story of
a Golden Retriever named Buddy that
played basketball basketball it brought
in a modest twenty three million dollars
at the domestic box office off of three
million dollar budget so a year later
dog sports fans got Air Bud golden
receiver this time the pooch played
football late football the movie fumbled
at the box office with less than an 11
million dollar domestic take but Disney
turned to the direct-to-video circuit to
keep the franchise going and going and
rapid succession buddy played soccer and
Air Bud World pub baseball in Air Bud
seventh-inning fetch in beach volleyball
in Air Bud Spike's back then came the
next generation the buddy's movies
focused on buddies puppies who anchored
nine adventures to date they've done
everything from battling supervillains
to learning the true meaning of
Christmas for those keeping count that's
13 sequels Death Wish this 1974 crime
thriller star Charles Bronson as a
regular guy who lays waste to every
street thug he encounters it resonated
with audiences providing a romanticized
solution to the danger and violence
plaguing city streets in the 1970s but
the inevitable death wish sequels turned
into generic action movies Charles
Bronson would utter equipped shoot a
cartoonishly evil thug and then repeat
between 1982 and 1987 cannon films
turned out death wish to death wish
three and death wish for the crackdown
the final entry in the increasingly
irrelevant series was the fashion world
centered for sequel Death Wish 5 the
face of death that came out in 1994 in
the series laid low for a while until
2018 when it became yet another reboot
anaconda the 1997 movie anaconda boasted
way too good of a cast for the kind of
movie it was Owen Wilson Jennifer Lopez
Ice Cube and Eric Stoltz played a
documentary crew traveling to the Amazon
River terrorized by a gigantic jungle
beast
the movie was generic and poorly
reviewed but it made 65 million
at the box office so anacondas the hunt
for the blood orchid followed in 2004 it
was virtually the same movie as anaconda
but with a group of researchers in
Borneo subbing in for the film crew in
South America that one took in about
half of the first movies hall so the
series retreated to television to
made-for-tv sequels followed anaconda
three offspring in 2008 and anacondas
trail of blood in 2009 the series is
fourth sequel was a 2015 crossover with
the similar 90s underwater creature
feature Lake Placid cleverly titled Lake
Placid vs. anaconda American Pie the
main characters from American Pie got
four whole movies and a complete plot
arc Jim Stifler Michelle and the rest
went to college in American Pie to
reunited for American Wedding and
reunited again for American Reunion but
its sequels don't end there along the
way the American Pie presents title has
been used mainly as a way to brand
raunchy comedies stuff like American Pie
presents Bandcamp and American Pie
presents betahaus just to name a few
Universal Soldier released in 1992
Universal Soldier was a fine entry in
the lineup of jean-claude Van Damme
action movies in the slick
science-fiction thriller JCVD plays a
fallen soldier who's revived as a
technologically enhanced super trouper
thanks to a top-secret military program
Van Damme returned for three direct
theatrically released sequels Universal
Soldier the return Universal Soldier
regeneration and Universal Soldier day
of reckoning that's a lot but there were
even more in the form of two made-for-tv
sequels in between the first two movies
Universal Soldier two brothers and arms
in Universal Soldier three unfinished
business the Land Before Time
in 1988 the Land Before Time was a rare
animated hit that wasn't a Disney movie
it brought in a whopping 84 million
dollars worldwide because what's not to
like it's about a bunch of cute
dinosaurs who have big adventures in
prehistoric times
kids always love dinosaurs but as they
outgrow their Dino phase and grow up
there are always more Dino cherishing
kids coming up behind them producers of
The Land Before Time have obliged with
an unrelenting number of sequels between
1994 and 2007 12 more Land Before Time
movies hit
video along with a reboot movie in 2016
bring it on the first bring it on was an
amusing self-effacing comedy about
competitive high school cheerleading
apparently there's a big demand out
there for movies about high stakes
cheerleading because five more bring it
on movies have hit home video while the
first starred Kirsten Dunst and
Gabrielle Union the others with titles
like bring it on again and bring it on
in it to win it have starred actresses
who are less famous or just starting now
the most recent iteration is called
bring it on worldwide cheer smack and is
about that's right a high school
cheerleading competition the pink
panther the majority of the Pink Panther
movies were directed by Blake Edwards
and served as a vehicle for British
comic genius Peter Sellars who
disappeared into the lead role of the
clumsy and incompetent French detective
Inspector Clouseau the Edwards Sellars
team up along with an iconic score by
Henry Mancini and opening animated
sequences featuring the literal Pink
Panther led to frequent movie magic the
pair made six Clouseau movies together
after sellers passed away in 1980 at
words tried to reboot the series twice
once with Roger Moore and once with
future Oscar winner Roberto Benigni
but that doesn't even account for the
rogue non sellers Pink Panther movies
from 1968 called Inspector Clouseau or
of course the two rebooted Pink Panther
films starring Steve Martin I don't even
own a Miss Planet of the Apes everybody
remembers the shocking twist ending of
the first Planet of the Apes movie from
1968 not as many remember that for the
first half of the 1970s a new Planet of
the Apes movie hit theaters every summer
like clockwork that's probably because
they lacked classic moments like the
ending of the first film or because
Charlton Heston didn't return to ham it
up
dirty ape each of the four sequels also
did worse at the box office than its
predecessor did add in tim burton's 2001
remake and the ongoing rebooted
franchise and you've got nine total
Planet of the Apes movies thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]